So
you were to have read today.
This section on classification is just a
small section,
right on categorization.
And then the next section on boss,
basically on the new buddy Alicia,
the rest of the taping and the creation
myth.
Okay.
Now that's the most fun.
That's the most archaic up creation
guest that we have in written form in
anything approaching a state of
completeness.
So it's interesting from a historical
perspective,
um,
because it's so archaic.
It's also an like the Mesopotamians has
an extraordinarily well developed dogma,
Religious Dogma as far as I've been able
to be terrible in some ways.
Well I think in,
in many ways Jewish and Christian
theology are elaborations on a mess of
attaining to think they'll eliod.
It points out the Mesopotamian creation
myth,
although it's about 5,000 years old and
seq stamp form is definitely based on
oral traditions that are much older than
that.
So it's not,
it's not like you can say that the
Sumerians just originated the Enuma
elish in a,
in a very brief period of time on ground
that haven't been prepared.
They just codify,
uh,
traditions that have been handed down
orally to that date and so we haven't
been written for it.
Now.
The first thing I wanted to tell you
about was this notion of categorization
and I think,
I think this is
Roger Brown pointed out with 20 years
ago or there about that time.
We have always in psychology tended to
think that the way that people think is
the way that scientists think and the
way that we categorize things is in
terms of the categories that we think
are appropriate from the scientific or
the logical perspective.
Brown points out that this is well that
is a minimal amount of investigation
basically in the cycle.
Linguistic domain immediately indicated
that this was in fact false and that we
do not categorize things naturally the
way that people do scientifically.
In other words,
we don't use the notion of the proper
set and he uses as a standard example of
the proper set,
the idea of triangles and you can tell
what a triangle is.
Absolutely.
You can define what's a triangle,
what isn't.
There's no fuzziness about the borders
and everything either fits in the set or
is outside of the set and by contrast
are natural categories don't seem to be
of that type.
They have fuzzy boundaries and they're
more concerned with function,
so to speak,
or with an effect of relevance than with
sensory and with swift.
Absolutely determinable sensory essence.
So we categorize in in much more vague
manner.
And it seems to me that I gave you the
listing in this,
in this document of the qualities of
natural categorization as they'd been
described by George Lakoff in his book,
a women fire and dangerous things and
lack off is basically following up on a
tradition as I'm not a psycho linguist,
and this is no new news to me basically.
But lakoff has been falling apart.
Church tradition that was established by
Roger Brown and Eleanor Ross,
who was one of his students and the
older elder has made a big name for
herself studying categorization.
The thing I think is so interesting
about this is that what Rosch and lakoff
describe as categories are very,
very much like the kinds of categories
that religious thinkers have used that
have been studied from a completely
different perspective by people like
[inaudible] and Mircea Eliade.
So it's not that surprising if you think
about it because it's obvious that
religious categories aren't proper sets,
their natural categories are can't
people in religious categories.
And I've always thought that way.
So it's not like it's,
it's not that surprising.
What's surprising our guests more
surprising is that the overlap between
the two literatures is,
is not well explored or,
no.
So,
uh,
the first thing we should do,
I guess is think to think about this
notion of categorization.
Yeah.
Okay.
Lakoff describes natural categories is
cognitive models.
So the first thing he says is that they
are embodied with regards to their
content,
which essentially means that they can be
used without necessarily being defined.
It means that they are implicit in
action without necessarily being
implicit and description.
So basically what lakoff is pointing out
is that if you act towards a number of
different things,
as if they are the same thing with
regards to your actions,
then you are in fact,
uh,
you are in fact treating those objects
as if they're in the same category.
Because one domain of category can be
fucked,
like significance for motor output.
And that's,
you think,
if you think about,
it's like what defines chair because
chair's very and all sorts of ways,
they vary so much that there's very,
there may be very little sensory overlap
between one chair and another if there's
not much.
There's not much similar between a
stump,
for example.
And the kind of designer chair that you
might see in a museum,
they're very different objects.
But the thing they have in common is
their implication for output,
which is the chairs are things that you
can sit on,
right?
They're defined by their,
by their significance in our under
sensory nature.
So I used an example here.
What makes a dog you?
You might say,
I can't say but I know one when I see
one,
which is another indication that you'd
be using a natural category,
the August something friendly,
something to be petted and something to
play with.
Although such knowledge does not
comprise everything that makes up you
regard his dog.
The thing that's interesting about those
ideas,
something friendly,
something to be petted and something to
play with is that in a sense those are
not precisely the attributes of the dog.
I think of a natural category of dog
because what you're,
if you define a dog as a friend or as
something to play with,
you're actually defining the object in
terms of your interactions with it and
not in terms of the object and a lot of
the terms we use have exactly that
nature.
Like beautiful.
For example,
it says when you define it,
say if you to find another person that's
beautiful.
It's very difficult to tell exactly
where it is that that quality besides,
I mean people say beauty's in the eye of
the beholder.
We know there's quite a substantial
amount of cultural variation in terms of
attitudes towards beauty.
So it's very difficult to pin down what
constitutes beauty from the objective
perspective.
I mean there's been a certain certain
attempts to do that and they've been
somewhat successful.
But the point is is that as beauty's in
the eye of the beholder,
but it's something that we naturally
attribute to an object.
So a lot of the things that we consider
properties of objects are actually what
lakoff describes his interaction with
properties.
There are things that we attribute to
the thing that actually arise as a
consequence of our interaction with the
thing.
So like the notion of friend,
when you,
when you describe,
if you put someone in the category of
friend,
you're actually describing them in terms
of your pattern of interactions with
them.
Although you attributed the qualities
that make up those interactions to them
and you do that automatically.
And what I'm suggesting with,
with regards to this study of
categorization is that we do that.
That is the natural way that we think is
we think about things in terms of their
implication for our behavioral output
and we need to do that because that's
what adaptation means and say a few of
adapt adapted to something.
You've structured your behavior well.
Basically what you've done is structure
your behavior in the presence of that
thing so that it does what you want it
to do,
which means basically that it doesn't
threaten you then it doesn't hurt you
that it furthers your progress towards
the goal or that it caused the
tombstone,
that goal itself.
That's behavioral adaptation and
well
those things,
the things that make up that category of
objects to which you've structured
behavioral adaptation that's explored
territory.
How's the domain of the known say in
that domain is everything that you
understand how to act towards.
Now what I'm trying to suggest in the
course of this whole manuscript,
because that's how your brain works,
the scientific overlay of scientific
categorizations is just a thin veneer on
top of that and in some sense it's
irrelevant.
The near from the perspective of
emotional regulation.
Science has enabled us to describe
things ever more accurate so that we can
keep track of them are still what we're
interested in is determining how to
behave in the presence of things.
That's what we want to know.
Okay.
Now lack off points on a few other
things about natural categories and I
want you to think about this in regards
to the sorts of categories that we're
going to talk about for the remainder.
Of course he says they're characterized
by basic level categorization and basic
level primacy and basically what he
means by that is that we tend to view
things as in a category or as objects to
themselves if they're the right size for
us.
In other words,
that the world that we perceive,
which is the world of experience,
which is in some sense doing world you
can get access to is human sized.
The cat.
There are categories that naturally
spring to mind because they're handy.
That's a good way of thinking about,
it's like the English imperial system of
measurement.
We can we define things in terms of
being English imperial system and it's
very handy.
Literally a foot is a foot long and
inches.
The length of one digit in the point
lakoff is trying to make is that the
world would have experienced presents
itself the way it presents itself
because of the interaction between our
physiology and whatever it is.
That's how we there and one of the
things that we're going to try to
explore is what does it mean to say
whatever it is that that's out there.
I mean we tend to think of it
scientifically as the objective world,
which would be exactly the same as it is
now if none of us were here except that
none of us would be here.
The point lakoff is trying to make is
that what we define as reality is
somewhat more or what were you
experiences?
Reality is more complex than that.
It's an interaction between whatever it
is that's out there and ask and
everything that we think of is real.
We defined like in terms of our
experience of temporal duration and size
and weight.
Okay.
I guess the only way,
the only way you can get your mind
around this to some degree is to try to
think of
what lakoff is saying in a sense is that
the fact that we're human and have the
characteristics that we have,
which are basically our limitations,
means that the universe is constituted
in a particular way with regards to us
is that we have a built in level of
analysis.
It's obviously not the sub atomic level
or at the molecular level and it's not
the cosmic level either.
It's human sized.
Now if you start thinking about what
would constitute reality in the absence
of a human observer,
the first problem that you run into is
the problem of a reference point is you
no longer have anything against which to
judge things like duration or size and
certainly not things like certainly not
things like color or beauty or emotional
significance.
Don't those categories obviously
disappear.
What happens to the sensory categories
is not all that easy to figure out
either.
I can't,
I already can't figure it out.
Would you find that in his book,
the Character Physical Mall discusses
encoding the nature of human experience
in a mathematical form and sending it to
an alien so that he could reconstruct
the world that we experience based on
the
proportion of an elemental character or
an element
or something like that.
And he gives a fairly good,
uh,
just from that,
it's convincing that you could describe
the world independent of human
experience.
If you define,
if you define the,
that,
that make up our capacity to experience
is that if you eat,
if you can just,
you could possibly describe the world
that we exceed the world in terms of
something which is transhumance by,
by,
by using mathematical symbols.
Well that's interesting.
So feynman says he,
he would define our level of analysis
mathematically as well as what it is
that we're experiencing.
And that would give an alien the
capacity to see what it is that we see.
He wasn't,
he wasn't talking about,
he was talking about a trans human
reality.
Fiman does mischief subject the reality
of reality to the presence of the
subject?
Right,
right.
Well anyway,
I got to,
the subject must have some sort of
intelligence that is,
it leaves me in some way where like our
own in order to interpret what we send
out there.
So just really not [inaudible]
so there's an alien out there who has a
similar enough intelligence to ours that
can,
that can understand this thing that
we've sent out.
I mean then then they're the subject in
question.
It opens up the,
it draws question too.
I mean it,
it sort of puts a question mark over the
possibility of seeing that reality is
dependent on that [inaudible] it's
ridiculous talking about reality in the
absence of the human subject.
Well,
trans human,
yes,
but trans subject,
no.
Okay.
One small difference between,
okay,
well I don't want to make too much of
this because it isn't,
it's knowing something that's critical
to the arguments that,
that we're going to,
we're going to undertake.
One of the things I want to tell you
about is how mythological categories
represent the category of all things
that exist in the absence of a subject,
but just kind of a strange category and
even the mythological,
like in the scientific world,
we presume an objective independent
reality.
I don't want to argue,
I certainly don't want to argue about
that because it's way too complicated an
issue,
but may have also presumes that
something exists in the absence of a
procedure or in the absence of a
subject.
Although the thing that exists is very
difficult to define and that's one of
the things we're going to take a brief
look at today because my,
my question is what does,
what does science have to do it and all
of that science,
another size is size of the,
of the,
uh,
of the raptors point that which presents
us up to the reference.
Well,
all the lack office basically saying is
that certain categories seem to present
themselves to us more naturally than
others.
Like the category cat presents itself to
us more naturally than the category of
species of cat because we naturally,
we're naturally predisposed,
so to speak,
towards making an object out of.
I was something like at cap now,
no one knows exactly why it is that
certain forms of categorization appeared
to us more nationally than other sorts.
I suspect it has something to do with
what you can say.
I have something to do with our
biological hard wiring,
which is not really much of an answer.
It's just the way and we are and we
perceive certain things more accurately
than we perceive other things.
I mean,
just to take a trivial example in,
in this room will focus all of our
attention on each other's face.
It's like I'm not going to spend a lot
of time when I'm talking to you,
looking at your hands.
My natural point of orientation in our
discussion is your face.
It's very significant for me,
and I think you see this sort of thing.
If you look at children's drawings,
I mean she's a child's drawing of a
person's,
you know,
usually something like this.
Maybe there's not even a body,
but the head is 90% of the person and
the face is 90% of the head.
And that's,
I think this is a protocol linguistic
representation of me of a human being.
Children tend to produce these sorts of
figures spontaneously.
I would say that's kind of a natural
hero glyphic that stands for person and
the things that are most relevant about
the person or the things that are
focused in on by the child.
It's just certain things appear to us
more naturally than other things and
those things more naturally constitute
our world.
So
talking about sides really quickly,
you returned to physics stuff and what's
intuitive that you can sort of look at
the,
you can sort of divide the universe into
three very basic levels of order to
magnitude.
You can have sort of what's intuitive.
There's the Newtonian universe we all
live in and you can have the cosmic
aware of which is sort of defined by
signing mechanics and space time.
And you can go to quantum mechanics,
which is smaller than you could possibly
perceive.
And if you,
if you look at the mathematics involved
in each one,
the Newtonian equations,
the ones that make sense to you that you
think in and the other ones seemed like
when you read about in the first time
you think to yourself,
how could this be?
But in a,
in a sort of mathematical sense,
they're all,
that's an excellent one because the
nature,
that's an excellent example because the
Newtonian universe is intuitive and the
reason that it's intuitive from the loch
coffee perspective is that the laws are
in accordance with our motor patterns
are patterns of adaptation.
I mean Psja is pointed out that we first
adapt to objects from the motor
perspective as a consequence of
exploration.
Then we build our abstract notions about
our relationships with those objects as
a consequence of our established motor
patterns.
So that basically that basically sums up
the notion of embodied knowledge.
And your point is that these other
universes are counter intuitive.
They,
they're not in accordance with our
experience.
Well that's partly because they aren't
the,
they aren't the left the levels of
resolution or the orders of magnitude
towards which we actually adapt our
behavior.
So yeah.
Okay.
Anyways,
you can finish reading through the,
uh,
the properties of natural categories.
They have interest in categories.
I also think that,
well,
membership and sensuality gradients is
kind of an interesting category,
uh,
as this familial resemblance.
The idea of familial resemblance is
quite interesting.
Basically what this is,
Raj has been coaching under the thing
that she's worked on.
Say if we have notions of prototypes
where our categories is that there's a
kind of an ideal thing that constitutes
the category,
the category bird people wouldn't say,
for example,
that robin is a more prototypical burden
than an ostrich and you can't exactly,
do you have a question?
Yeah.
Maybe it's not really a way to what
you're saying,
right.
But do we sort of subconsciously
concrete different categories or find
things easier in a categorized?
And what we see,
I mean now we'd all look at each other's
faces,
but if you have dreams,
you can sort of identify somebody.
Even if they look completely
differently,
you can say,
you know,
and I knew in my dream this was supposed
to be your father.
Even though he looked like my math
teacher,
they maybe are we sharing of getting out
of different subconscious of essence of
people?
Then when we
in in a dream or I don't know.
I don't know.
I know what you're saying and people.
Yeah.
I mean there must be some other
category,
some other way of categorizing.
Yeah.
I guess what happens in,
in,
in a situation and dream like that is
that you have to conflict in
categorizations of one takes
predominance.
So you say,
despite all these exceptions,
the product,
typical aspects of this,
whatever it is,
are still intact.
So we're not,
you'd have to look at the individual
differences in the dreams to be able to
do your own exactly.
Exactly how that happens.
But this is the prototypical Smith brunt
of this is,
you know,
your classic example.
How do you identify some family members
is coming from all from the same family.
You have all these Smith brothers,
there's five of them,
and you can all tell their brothers,
but they don't share the same complete
set of characteristics is the
prototypical brother.
Maybe he has six characteristics.
So you might say,
well a big nose would be one and the
heavy mustache would be another kind of
beard would be a third big years and be
a fourth and heavy eyebrows from vfm in
glasses say would be a six.
So that's your prototype people,
Smith's brother.
But to be recognizable as a smith
brother,
perhaps you only have to have two of
these characteristics and the rest can
vary.
So this character would have big ears
and eyes and maybe the mustache,
but he didn't have a little nose and no
beard.
And then this character would have the
glasses and a big nose and mustache.
A little areas I,
I'll say a beard anyways,
you get the idea and they don't share.
They're not like triangles.
You can't precisely define the captain
characteristics that this myth,
Brett Smith brothers half,
theoretically the old rate to this
relate to this central prototype which
we abstract from our experience in some
complex manner.
So the notion of
what else is interesting.
Well the other thing about natural
categories is that instead of being
distinct,
like,
like a proper sets as make it overlap.
And this is part of the reason that,
well knowing this helps you make sense
of it,
the logical categories because they
shift with context.
Unfortunately that makes them difficult
to interpret.
For example,
one of the most basic divisions of the
world from a mythological perspective as
masculine versus feminine.
And that's related in a very profound
way to explore a territory versus saw
unexplored territory.
Um,
the problem is is that whether or not
something is masculine or feminine tends
to depend on the context of
interpretation.
So for example,
if you talk about an island and the
ocean,
then the island is masculine and notions
feminine.
But if you talk about an island in the
sky,
then the island is feminine and the sky
is masked.
But so we,
even though the island is theoretically
objectively the same in both
circumstances,
it's cloud.
It's an effect of classification,
shifts with context.
Now you might think,
well that's a bizarre property for a
categorization have.
The thing is we do this all the time.
This is actually how we derive meaning
in large part.
It's always context dependent.
Like most of the words you know,
you don't know because someone told you
the meaning of them.
You know because you derive the meaning
from the context.
You see a normal word,
one context,
and then in another context and then in
another context and you can derive the
meaning from from from analysis of
what's common across the context.
Maybe you can define it novel where if
you saw it in 10 different sentences,
you have enough information there to
figure out what the word means and the
meaning of the word shifts with the
sentence.
In this meaning of the sentence shifts
with the paragraph and the meaning of
the paragraph shifts with the essay.
That's why you can pull things out of
context and reversed their meaning
often.
So the fact of context dependent meaning
has gone up that much of a mystery
cause everything happened.
I'm a little confused
when you see a door or something.
Okay.
Now someone can say that they see a door
and it has,
you know,
they,
it has sensory,
you know,
information like it's a door you open
and close it but they feel nothing
towards it.
Right.
But does it have value?
Well it's only,
it's always last week for example,
we talked about the relationship of
things to your story.
You have your story
and um,
like if part of your ideal future
doesn't have it doesn't have any
relevance unless it interferes.
No,
no,
not only interferes with if it aids.
Do you think,
what,
look again,
whatever it looks to me like your cortex
evolved in part to modulate the
automatic reactions of your limbic
system to stimuli to make it more
flexible.
How it looks to me like what's happening
is that what your cortex has done is
high jack,
your limbic system.
In this way it says you can put anything
you want into the goal box,
but as soon as you put it there,
it's a conservatory reward.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Now you have a lot of underlying
biological systems,
but how has their own idea about what
should be here,
but you can still put whatever you want
in there.
It's a conservatory reward now.
As soon as you do that,
everything that you encounter is
construed in relationship to that goal.
So the door is only relevant if you need
to get through it to get to where you
want to go.
Right now it's not relevant at the end
of the class.
It will.
Absolutely,
and you shift the significance of things
by shifting your framework of reference
and what we're trying to define this.
What constitutes a framework of
reference.
That's one thing.
What is a framework of reference?
I would say in terms of natural
categories,
everything within here is of one type of
thing and everything outside of it is
I'm a completely different type of thing
and I tried to define that as the known
and unknown.
Or You could say as,
and I really think this is,
I've been trying to chase
say categories have this central
prototype and there's all sorts of
mythological categories.
Masculine,
this one category and feminine is
another,
a sky as a category and earth is it a
category matter as a category and water
as a category because things overlap in
some odd way,
like sky tends to be related to
masculine.
For example,
I've been trying to chase down what's at
the core of these mythological
categories and that's why I come up with
these terms.
No woman unknown.
And then there's the process of
mediation that's the knower.
Or You could say,
and maybe this is even more fundamental,
the unknown.
It's unexplored territory.
The no one has explored territory
and the knower is the explorer and
that's how we conceive of the world.
The world is made up.
Yes,
yes.
And this,
that's it.
That's how our brain naturally organizes
things.
How come?
Um,
I was a little confused.
How come that the heavens or the sky is
considered masculine and cans?
We would think known territory because
compared to the earth it seems like it's
more unknown.
Good question.
Okay,
well have to think about that part of
the answer.
There's two masculine categories and
that's part of the answer is the
explored territory tends to be the king.
Do you think the old king Michael Cirrus
or example,
where does the knower tends to be
masculine as well as usually the sun,
that's horace say or Marduk and these
are usually skype bonds.
They're assimilated to the sun,
the sun as assimilated to consciousness.
So that's basically the answer to that.
The sky is the domain of the sun.
The Sun is massive.
Why is the Sun Masculine?
Well,
because it's associated with
consciousness,
illumination,
enlightenment,
it rate it rules during the times when
we are conscious.
It's also the thing that fights the
dragon of chaos in the night packs.
It's way out in the belly of the beast
and then is born again
in the morning.
So that's,
that's the answer,
that question.
I could think of a way,
but the sky could be explored.
Territory relative theory,
people who never thought of going up in
this guy,
this guy is not something you move
through,
but something it's over you.
And to that extent it is exploring.
It's very predictable.
And even if you move a great distance
across Europe,
this guys is relatively the same.
Where's your changes?
Inadequate,
right?
Yeah.
That,
that can be as well.
It's also the case,
you have to remember,
and this is one of the things that makes
analysis of mythological symbols tricky.
They do shift with context and they're
not always culturally stable.
For the Sumerians,
this guy who was male and the earth was
female,
but for the Egyptians,
the sky was female and the earth was
male.
That's more rare,
but it does happen.
What seems to be,
well,
so you have to look at,
you have to look for the prototype
that's at the core of this to try and
make sense of it.
The shifting relationships.
So the mother earth notion is more
common.
Laptop.
The fatherland is also a mythological
notion,
right?
You fight for the fatherland,
we fight for the man.
Those two ideas have slightly different
slants.
It seems like to call the explorer
predictable,
unexplored,
the unpredictable might be just as
fundamental.
Yes,
yes.
Fair,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
That's another,
that's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at it as well.
And that's,
that's basically where you see the,
uh,
neuropsychological overlap instantly
because we do know now that you're
emotional systems are our a priori
hardwired to respond to the
unpredictable.
That's a domain.
Now it looks to me like in terms of
neuro psychological function,
then the left hemisphere of the
linguistic hemisphere,
it's specialized for habitual patterns
of action.
It looks to me like it's the hemisphere
that rules and known territory.
Okay.
You say,
well,
your brain is actually wired up so that
it,
it has one set of responses that are
useful when you know what the hell
you're doing.
And then it has a whole other set of
subsystems that are useful when you
don't know what you're doing.
And when you do know what you're doing
is the linguistic left.
That's it's you.
And when you don't know what you're
doing,
it's the limbically dominated right
hemisphere that then appears to mediate
your actions.
Now why would I say that?
Oh,
it's part of it.
Because we know the right frontal cortex
responds to punishment and threat.
Trevor,
the APR already phenomenon that appear
with the appearance of the
unpredictable.
So the right hemisphere is what governs
your behavioral responses.
When you encounter something you do that
you can predict in terms of it's more
cognitive functions.
Well,
governance,
anxiety,
that's for sure.
It may govern pain.
That's not so clear,
but it looks like it's,
it looks like there's a high possibility
governs depression anyways.
Um,
it's also the part of your brain that's
good at recognizing patterns and
generating stories.
And my guess is that you can think about
this.
If you encounter something you don't
understand,
the first thing you tried to do is to
figure out how it's like other things
you've already encountered,
which is basically to say that when
you're first trying to adapt to
something that you don't,
can't predict,
you try to apprehend in it familiar
patterns say well even people who just
with the sky then that's how we get the
constellations had this massive,
an undiscovered territory that
constitutes the night sky.
You chunk it into patterns and that
makes it identifiable and you have
stories that revolve around the patterns
and you start to move the information
from the domain of the unknown into the
domain of familiar territory.
And when you think about it,
the right hemisphere is the hemisphere
that seems to be specialized for for
stories and for fantasy.
And it is fantasy is hypothesis
generation as far as I can tell,
a fantasy is the story of well maybe
it's like this and your and your right
hemisphere seems to be good for that.
So then you have a nice set of
functions.
It's the thing that is activated when
you encounter something unpredictable.
So it stops you,
it makes you shut up and look,
and then the next thing it does is just
start thinking it's specialized for
global pattern recognition.
Recognition wants to give you a quick
and dirty answer.
What's out there?
Well now,
right hemisphere thinks,
well it's like this.
It's like this.
It's like this and it gives you a
picture.
So you get something like,
I'm like Kelly who will encounter and a
little bit later who's a,
who's a monster that inhabits the
unknown.
That's basically composed of determinant
things that are frightening.
So like Kelly was the goddess of the
unknown.
She has staring face big teeth,
she sits in fire,
she has eight legs like a spider.
She's a picture of the thing that lives
the out there in the unknown.
Anyways.
Okay.
Back.
Can you elaborate on how the left
rewards in the business as well?
It seems to be,
it seems to be more specialized for
information that you already know how to
handle.
And it also,
it's also good at handling
linguistically mediated information that
by the time you've chopped up the world
into units that you can describe with
words,
you've already done a pretty good job of
adapting to it.
You can even have straggly represented
if,
if you're still,
I think action is a form of
categorization.
If you really don't know something,
all you know about is the in its
presence.
You should stop or run.
That's a form of categorization.
It's pretty generalized information,
right?
By the time you've explored something
really thoroughly,
you can describe it and words and you
can communicate it,
and that seems to me part of what the
left hemisphere does,
but it's also responsible.
We think about it this way.
The left frontal hemisphere is also
responsible for the generation of
positive aspect.
Now,
you only generate positive ethic in the
presence of cues of conservatory reward
in the presence of incentive rewards.
Now,
incentive reward is something that
indicates that you're getting closer to
your goal.
Okay?
Now explored territory is basically full
of indications that you're getting
closer to your goal.
That's why it's explored,
right?
Because you've already transformed it
from something unknown and threatening
into something that you can use to get
to where you want to go.
And the left hemisphere does that.
So it looks to me like,
well it looks to me like those things
all sort of fit together.
Adoptation basically means in its,
in its most optimal sense,
adaptation means that you transform
something you do not understand into
something that you can not only predict
but can you,
because you just don't want to transform
everything into something irrelevant,
right.
That would be useless.
You want to transform things.
You don't understand the things that you
can do something with that you want to
do.
So,
so at the individual has a different
balance through which they approach like
the youth,
like the balance between the left and
right hemisphere or the first two.
Well there's,
there's some evidence for variation and
temperament.
You know,
some people are more inhibited and some
people are less inhibited.
Now the problem with that is that I
believe that,
I mean it does look like there's pretty
solid evidence for these temperamental
variations.
So you might say that you have a lower
threshold,
for example,
for experiencing anxiety in the presence
of something or a new one,
then the next person does and that's to
cross situation.
The problem with that is that it doesn't
take into account the fact that what's
unexpected is always construed in
relationship to the story,
but my guess is that if people looked
into this,
they find it inhibited.
People have different stories about the
way the world is constructed and part of
their biological predisposition towards
timidity manifest itself in the
structure of the stories they tell
themselves about the world.
It makes sense because if you're more,
you're more frightened by people.
The stories you tell about them are
going to be twisted more towards the
domain of threat.
So those
does that balance also very
situationally,
like you said,
if if someone is refusing groups up in
all this information that does have
relevance to their story and they're
ignoring it until it gets to a certain
point where they can foresee,
yeah,
I think there are a whole last half of
the course is about that.
It's like because one of the things that
you can do to yourself to make yourself
more pathological and just know how to
adapt to normal,
his information and that makes you
function with pathological.
I think
so.
Would that actually make the right
hemisphere less reactive or we didn't
make it yet?
It would make,
it would make a left,
I don't know.
Compensating function or is it,
I think it,
I think what happens in those
circumstances does the right hemisphere
starts to make a lot of noise so your
dreams start to,
or one of the students I had last been
open the in the class this past last
year has just written a paper for me on
the potential function of dreams.
He points out that in in neural map,
in neural net modeling of pattern
recognition,
there's a phenomena called catastrophic
failure where if you have a neuro debt
and it's going to a bird category and a
fish category and you'd throw in a
penguin,
well what happens is that the bird
county going to fish category collapsed
and all you get is animal category.
So there's kinds anomalous information
that will blow a whole categorization
systems.
So what he paused it was that there's
one system that has,
that does categorization and another
that's slowly feeds at anomalous
information so it doesn't collapse.
So it has time to adjusted structure to
the new anomalous information,
but blowing into a categorization
scheme.
Now you have to have a categorization
scheme because if you don't,
you don't know how to act.
And if it's really global,
like if I tell you,
you say,
well how do I write an essay?
And I said you act like a human being.
So this is pretty,
this information is so vague as to be
completely useless for the task at hand.
You want to categorize it,
you want information that's sort of
sufficiently high resolution so that it
will aid you in your task.
If I blow all your categorization sets
and you're just left with this really
amorphous,
amorphous categorization,
you don't know how to act.
So you want to maintain your categories.
What he suggested was wasn't the dream
slowly moving almost information up into
that categorization schemes.
So,
and in terms of your question,
well if you,
if you constantly ignore anomalous
information pouring in from the right
hemisphere,
basically what you've done is categorize
more and more information into the
category of things that are so terrible
they can't be faced.
And I think what you do under those
circumstances,
you activate a monster,
so to speak,
that lives in your right hemisphere.
And it gets more and more and more
powerful until one day when at a weak
moment say it just swallows you whole.
And that's when you fall catastrophic.
We into depression or into terrible
anxiety or maybe even depending on your
physiological predisposition to
something resembling schizophrenia.
So Katie,
you keep,
because all that information that you've
encountered that's anomalous and scag
rocks,
you categorize it by avoiding it.
And the category is so terrible.
I can't face it.
So you think that if you integrate it,
you don't end up with nightmares?
Yes,
that's right.
That's right.
Although if you haven't been integrating
and then you start,
the nightmares might increase in
intensity.
And it's also the case that when you are
dreaming,
you know,
your,
uh,
your spinal cord,
your reticular activating system,
the part is activating the hippocampus
and the Amygdala.
And that's the part of the brain that
deals with anomalous information.
It reverts to two brainstem control.
So it looks to me like this is a good,
this is a reasonable hypothesis.
You have a system that deals with what
you know and another one that deals with
what you don't do.
You need both.
If you ignore one,
well,
there's a whole social psych literature
that says if you ignore anomalous
information,
you're happier.
You know,
which is that,
that's a really appalling literature
because they don't take temporal
duration into consideration.
It's real good in the short term.
What,
what are really,
oh,
there's a whole,
yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
The positive illusions literature is
Taylor or,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's being,
it's being trashed with empirical data
showing that,
yeah.
In the short terms,
good solution for the long term.
You know you get hostile and anxious and
depressed and people don't like you very
much,
which is you know,
hardly all that surprising but they
actually wrote self help books,
self help books telling people that
positive self legions would good for
mental health man.
Despite like 5,000 years of
philosophical evidence to the contrary,
both of these hemisphere,
right hemisphere working at the same
time.
When you come across experience,
what would happen to a split brain
patient?
Is there been any,
any,
well we do know for example that,
I don't know,
I don't know the literature on emotional
responsivity of split brain patients,
but I do know that if you sustain right
frontal cortical damage,
it makes you inappropriately northern
depressed and anxious.
And what that,
what happens under those circumstances
is that you acquire functional
psychopathy,
which basically means that psychopath
doesn't regulate his behavior as a
consequence of information that
indicates that his behavioral output is
doing something that in the long run is
it's a bad idea.
Well,
there's a,
there's a famous paper by Islam and
demands you about a guy who uh,
can't remember his initials.
He had an Iq of 143,
right frontal damage,
no measurable decrements in Iq.
So he's still 143 is three standard
deviations above the mean.
We're talking very bright person here,
but he makes series of catastrophic
decisions that look,
that are up,
the sort that you'd associate with
stupid criminality.
He,
uh,
gets divorced,
he marries Ah,
uh,
well,
someone who is very bad for him
basically gets involved in a whole
series of terrible business decisions,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So if you're missing the information
from your right frontal Cortex,
you're happy.
No kidding,
because you've knocked out the whole
system that deals with all those things
that make you unhappy,
but you have to be unhappy to live
properly
when you encounter those things,
the dope go out according to plan
because if you don't attend to those
things that don't occur according to
plan,
then you don't learn.
And if you don't learn,
you keep your model of adaptation stable
in the face of,
in the face of shifting environmental
contingencies and what that basically
means is that over time the thing that's
you gets old and senile and that's how
it's represented.
Mythology by the way,
and that's the,
that's the image of the wasteland.
No,
that's the land where all the trees have
dried up and everything's all,
nothing grows and you can read that as
the absence of the positive aspect of
the great mother,
which means that there's no beneficial
novelty around or you can read that as
the tyranny of stupid if you all would.
Either way.
You're suggesting that.
Are you suggesting that in the apps and
so a connection the left brain will
dominate?
Probably one of them.
I think that's true,
like this is speculative,
but there's some,
there's some physiological evidence like
the left brain,
the left hemisphere is in most
circumstances in schizophrenia.
For example,
if you're a schizophrenia and you start
hearing voices,
it appears as though there's a
possibility that the reason for that is
because the areas that are associates
that are isomorphic with the language
centers but are in the right hemisphere
have been released from tonic inhibition
by the language centers in the left
hemisphere and our start to become
active.
And the way you interpret that is I hear
voices,
they aren't me.
So which,
which suggests to me that who you are as
far as you're concerned is mostly the
sum total of linguistically mediated
processes that localized usually the
left hemisphere but mostly their
linguistic.
We immediate,
which is only to say that mostly what
you are as far as your own self regard,
he's a culturally constructed entity,
most of which has been constructed using
the mediation of language that's up
settlement.
No,
no one won't be because first of all
there isn't consciousness.
There's a bunch of processes that are
consciousness now.
Like one consciousness that's clearly
conscious is what happens to you when
something enormous occurs.
Because you will orient towards that.
And I think orienting is most central to
what we define as consciousness.
Because like even in this room,
look,
there's only a few things that you're
really conscious of.
You're very much not conscious as a
general rule of the floor,
the ceiling,
the walls,
most things around you.
The only thing you're conscious of is
that part of your experiential field
where there's some novelty emerging,
right?
That's because you're orienting systems
are activated and those are critical to
consciousness.
And this is very interesting because in
mythology
and mythology,
one of the things that brings about the
war,
the world is the capacity to
discriminate between things,
capacity to attend to novelty.
Um,
well I want,
I want to get into that.
Of course,
today's discussion actually
see,
look,
when you're orienting towards things
you're attending to the world that's
defined by chaos and transforming it
with the intermediation of exploration
into defined territory from the
mythological perspective,
that's equivalent to the construction of
the world.
Now that's why in in Christian theology,
for example,
there's the doctrine of the logos.
The logos is being assimilated to
consciousness.
It's a solar light entity mediated by,
by,
by language.
That's why it's the word.
It's also a simulated to Christ,
and this is not a notion that's unique
to Christianity as we'll see.
That's the thing that creates the world,
creates the world by dividing.
Look,
here's an example.
In the earliest Sumerian mess,
there's a dragon who lives in the
primordial waters and he gives rise to
two wedded daddy's once the sky and the
others,
the earth,
they're separate,
but not really.
And the way the myth represents that is
that they're locked in something
technically called a Hieros Gamos,
which is a mystical marriage.
So they're in sexual union,
they're united.
They're not really two things.
There are union gives rise to a third
force.
That's their sun,
the god of the atmosphere.
As it turns out the scenario,
it's the God is the atmosphere who
separates them,
pushing the sky up to the sky and the
first out of the earth and thereby
creates the world.
What the hell does that mean?
Well,
it means that in any creation myth,
there's four elements,
chaos and once chaos.
That's the union of everything.
That will one at one point be distinct
and in sometimes represented methodology
by the Indian,
between the mother and the infant,
cause that's sort of symbiotic,
right?
Ones absolutely dependent on the other,
but yet in a sense they're two distinct
entities where they will be two
distinctive,
but anyways,
chaos.
That's the dragon
that lives at the bottom of the water.
It gives rise to two days.
Earth and the sky.
They're law,
conceptual union.
They give rise to a sun.
The God of the atmosphere.
This is the sun gone.
He separates them.
That's the world.
Now you could say the world is born as a
consequence of the interaction of the
sky.
God in the Earth,
God or you could say that the world was
born as a consequence of the fact that
the Sun God separates the two.
Most stories are accurate.
All this stories saying you have to look
at the mythological representations.
The story say,
well the earth,
this is chaos there.
If that's a maternal,
that's the mother.
Okay,
that's normal.
It's the source of all things.
Sun.
God separates these two things by
discriminating between them,
which is basically by taking the thing
that's novel and transforming it into
the thing that's explored.
That means the origin of the cosmos from
the mythological perspective.
So there's three,
there's three seminal out elements in in
your standard creation myth.
The mother,
the father,
and the son,
and the mother is the unknown,
unexplored territory.
The fathers,
the known explored territory and the sun
is the process that mediates between
them.
And I have assimilated that the
orienting reflects because it's the
thing that focuses in on novelty,
initiates the process of exploration,
which is the process by which the
determinant world is form.
Thank well why does the determinant
world under those circumstances?
Well,
it's all those places that you can go
where you know how to behave and those
places consist of the territory but also
the behaviors of everyone else but you
interact with.
So Nolan territory is social territory
because all of our actions in habitual
are defined by the actions of others.
So part of what it is that we know when
we say we know how to map the actions
and interactions of others.
So that's why the no one is also similar
culture
and to the Patriarchy and
the cane.
Because of course the king is the
behavioral model that defines the state
who everyone in the state imitates so
that everyone in the state can predict
everyone else.
That's part of it.
Anyways,
so for me you're explored territory
because I can define what you're going
to do with this situation and the reason
I can define us cause we shared the same
story,
which is what we're pursuing.
Goals there are at least concurrent,
they don't conflict because they
conflicted.
We'd have trouble because you be mapping
things with one motivational
significance and I'd be mapping the Mfi
other,
which basically means we either have to
negotiate,
which means you'd arrange your story and
I'd arrange mind or we fight.
That's,
that's it.
Those are the two options.
Or I can pretend that the conflict
doesn't exist,
in which case sooner or later it will
get me.
Now I want to,
because this is a course about social
identity and social conflict.
I want to read you some or get to one,
one sec.
I want to read you some things for
Mircea Eliade because it'll help you.
It will help you understand how it is
that we naturally categorize things.
So you want to remember chaos because
that's the thing that we're,
we're going to discuss.
They'll
chaos is what exists before there's a
separation of subject and object and the
thing that chaos is is then both spirit
and matter.
Terrible mythological way of speaking.
I'll give you an example of what that
means.
Piaget said that the subject constructs
himself as well as the object in the
course of exploration,
which basically means that what you are
formed out of is all those things that
you discovered as you were approaching
all those things you didn't know.
Now you form the world has a consequence
of the process of exploration,
but you also form yourself because it's
in the process of encounter with novelty
that you generate information and it's
information that you build your cell
phone.
So from the mythological world,
the thing that's chaos that existed
before the world existed is composed of
spirit,
which is what you will be and mattered
simultaneously,
which is very,
that sounds very interesting.
Quonset.
Okay.
Question.
Oh,
okay.
All alright.
I don't want to go off into different
groups.
No.
The symmetry between the pros and goal
process and then the state one.
Chaos state.
Yeah.
And then the known nowhere.
No,
unknown knower.
No.
Yeah.
So the knower is in the place of the
process.
The know raise the process.
So no worries.
The process.
So
becomes the mechanism,
which your body's
the process.
Yeah.
Or something.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
And that's what religious stories
basically push you towards.
That's why I wanted to show you this
story.
Martech.
Martech is the person who encounters
the,
I know.
I'm the God who attains the highest
position in the hierarchy of Gods.
Who then goes out to fight time.
Who's the dragon of both?
She's both the dragon of chaos and the
mother of all things.
Those two categories get overlapped some
stairs and in the,
in the fight with timeout,
Marta generates the cosmos.
Now the Mesopotamian King Imitates
Marduk.
That's what gives him power.
That's,
that's what gives his position validity,
is the fact that he's the embodiment of
the Sun God.
But what does that mean?
Well,
the Sun God is the thing that makes the
world well.
What does that mean?
Well,
the sunken garden is an image of the
process of consciousness,
which turns the unknown,
which is undefined territory,
into explored territory,
which is the world.
And as long as the king,
so then the arcade people say the state,
if the king doesn't do his job,
the state becomes sterile.
Crops don't grow,
for example.
And you say,
what the hell?
Trying to quit warrant.
How they all kind of attitude is that if
the king doesn't do his job,
crops won't grow.
Well,
what it means is the king is a pattern
of adaptation.
If he doesn't constantly update his
behavioral attributes in the space of
shifting environmental contingencies,
the beneficial aspect of the environment
will disappear.
So when they are caring,
people says,
if the king doesn't do his job,
then the state becomes say,
no crops won't grow there,
Dan.
Right.
What do they do?
He killed the king,
sacrifice the king,
or he has to undergo a ritual that
indicates salary sacrifice,
which actually the king of Mesopotamia
did every new years when he renewed the
cosmos,
he had to do that.
Cause if he didn't renew the cosmos,
which basically meant update his pattern
of behavioral adaptation representation,
then the environment would drift farther
and farther away from the state and
everything would collapse precipitously.
So the king had to voluntarily and
counter novelty or in the long term,
he would catastrophic.
We encounter it along with all those
people anyway.
Okay.
Last semester.
Can you relate that somehow to why money
has value or the use of coins?
Oh yeah.
That's a funny one though,
right?
Well,
a gold coin has the,
the head of
the head of a head of state on it.
Why?
Well,
the gold is a symbol of the sun and the
sun is the Sun God and the emperor is
put on the toy.
Did you indicate value?
Because this is the thing that is most
valuable and it's symbolic
representations of that that we've used
to signify province basically.
So yeah.
Yeah,
gold is always been assimilated to the
sun at least in the west,
so okay.
Now I want to read you some things from
Elliot and I think these things are well
from the perspective of social
psychology and the notion of
understanding conflict and the hopes for
its revolution resolution,
these sorts of things.
I think your revolutionary if you
understand their significance because
the only out he basically describes how
it is that people naturally perceive
those who are not like them.
No,
I wouldn't say,
well,
if I'm like you,
I share your story.
Okay.
This is a castle.
We're both inside.
I can construe your relationship to me
with regards to our end goal.
That's,
I also am going to get to this later.
This is also a dominance hierarchy.
The kings at the top of it and every
organization is set up that way.
It's like if you and I are both,
if you and I in a hundred other people
are pursuing the same goal,
we organize ourselves into a dominance
hierarchy.
We each have a position that basically
constitutes a sub goal of that greater
goal and the utility of the goals are
rank ordered in terms of their
importance and the person who's at the
top is simultaneously the most important
person in the dominance hierarchy and an
embodiment of the goal.
Chief Executive Officer in a corporation
for example.
How you can also relate that in thinking
about that this week too,
the more complex stories,
remember it looks like this
and so on.
Now the thing that's neat about this is
this is also you remember,
does everybody remember how this works?
Is that the story is actually consists
of sub stories basically all the way
down.
Now the higher you are up on the
dominance hierarchy,
the closer you are to the broadest
expanse of this story.
So if you're just a functionary in an
organization,
you have one of these stories and
anything that comes along to disrupt
you,
like if you get fired is only going to
bond or people who are working on that
particular sub goal.
Now if you're the king or the chief
executive officer,
you occupied this territory.
So like in the case of a,
of a hostile takeover of a corporation,
that means the whole structure is
potentially disruptive and everyone
inside that structure feels anxiety and
depression because their stories are
being disrupted.
Okay.
Now you can also see how groups form in
relationship to this because you're,
you're most tightly identified with
those who share the most at the most,
the broadest subset of your embedded
stories.
So
does that make sense?
Would you say that to response to
Kennedy's assassination?
Right.
Perfect.
Exactly.
More accurately in the north when the
North Korean emperor died,
people said the sun had set,
the sun had permanently,
people were on the street wailing and
crying,
you know,
carrying around pictures of the sun,
God who disappeared because the whole
state was placed into chaos.
But at the same thing happens when,
when,
uh,
when Stalin died,
for example,
when any tire and dies because of the
tire is well in bodies and bodies,
the story of the state killed the
tyrant.
Everything collapses.
People come out in the streets and cry.
Yeah.
Fry points out that people like Queen
Elizabeth still draw crowd because lots
of people still thinking of medieval
fashion,
so to speak,
but more accurately Queen Elizabeth in
bodies or stories,
everyone's story.
She's the,
she's the focal point you could say.
Or She's the person who incarnates the
abstract and stories now so you can say
that or overtop of her objective reality
is laid.
Uh,
uh,
I don't know how many describe it.
A glamorous
facade that people see you because of
their subjective interpretations and she
acts out that role.
That's right.
That's projection.
Say That's a good example of projection.
They think that what they're so excited
about is the queen.
It's her attributes.
But you can say in a sense that's true.
It's what she signifies for behavior.
But that's not exactly a property of the
object.
No.
Is it?
Now if you can understand that,
you get very close to understanding what
it is that our people are referring to,
what they were referring to.
A God cause it Queen Elizabeth in a
sense is an incarnated to go out and
the,
the more potent gods occupied broader
domains of the story.
You know what the Mesopotamians said,
and this is the core for religious
stories in general,
is that the thing that should be at the
top of the hierarchy is Marta,
right?
Marduk was elected by all the other gods
to be the cane gone.
He's the process by which it normally is
transformed into explored territory and
what that basically means that if in
your hierarchy of values was placed
above all else is the necessity of
responding to a normally every time it
manifests itself,
then all your other biological systems
that determine value will operate
properly.
And if you put something else in the
place of that
God,
so to speak,
then sooner or later everything will
fall into chaos.
That's that.
That's what those mythological stories
and try to tell people that your
attitude towards anomaly that determines
everything and you have two choices.
You to face it voluntarily or no,
and if you don't,
well,
that's why we're reading Milton's
paradise lost because Milton's paradise
lost is a story about the consequences
of voluntarily voluntary failure to
admit to the existence of the normally.
Okay.
Now,
so you see,
you read the story of Martech,
the Samarian myth.
It's very,
very interesting.
You say all those gods,
they organized themselves into a
dominance hierarchy,
so they're threatened by timeout.
She's the dragon of chaos.
She con she caused the dude's unexplored
territory.
She's going to destroy all the gods,
create creator.
God's always do that and that's because
the unknown generates everything and
takes everything back,
so it has this ambivalent motivational
status,
the source of everything kind of place
that everything returns to.
It's a constant threat.
It never goes away.
There's always something you don't have.
You don't expect to deal with.
The gods organized themselves into a
hierarchy and they put Marta cat the
talk.
Then he's the king.
Okay.
It seems to me that what that story is
telling you with regards to the
construction of the dominance hierarchy
is two things.
It's first of all,
the Mesopotamian society was the
consequence of the intermingling of a
whole set of cultural groups.
Each of them had their own God,
which is basically their own
representation of the highest ideal,
projected more or less into the external
world.
Now there was a lot of differences
between these representations,
but in the process of becoming one
culture,
all these gods had to fight it out,
so to speak,
for dominance in the territory defined
by interpersonal communication.
And the myth of Marta climbing the
dominance hierarchy is the story,
the cumulative story of the combat
between these gods and the rise of one
clock,
two preeminent status.
Now you can see at the end here,
yeah,
on page 96 I don't know how many of you
have your book,
but Marduk still in the Sumerian Myth
Mesopotamian myth.
Martin still has a whole bunch of sort
of other names that were likely the
names of gods who sooner or later became
assimilated to Marduk.
He sort of took over their domain and
the Mesopotamian said that mark had,
I don't remember how many names cst,
and here are some of them.
And so what the Mesopotamians basically
concluded unconsciously,
so to speak,
was that whenever Martech represented
was also vital to what all these other
names representative.
And here are some of the names he's Nam
to lack of who's the God who restores to
life.
Okay.
That he's describing his role in the
process that we
I'm talking about.
Yes.
Okay.
Chaos.
Impulse.
Yeah.
When the Mesopotamia Martech is the God
who restores to life,
this is what they need.
Here's this process,
this being read as death,
stale state rejuvenation process.
That's more deck.
That's named number one who can restore
all ruined gods as though they were his
own creation.
The God Lord who who by holy incantation
restores the dead thoughts to light.
Same thing.
This is the dad doors and you can say,
well why is that
while your behavioral patterns of
adaptation or the consequences in the
final analysis of your mimicry of all
those people who came before you and
established moans,
exploration driven modes of adaptation,
which is to say that what do you consist
of in terms of your behaviors is the
cumulative behaviors of your whole
culture in so far as those would be
adaptively relevant and most of those
were established by people who are now
dead ancestral fingers in many
religions,
the ancestral figures or assimilated to
God and that's because they determine
your behavior.
Then when
the unknown is the domain of the dead
gone.
So that's basically,
there's an interesting little side is a
piece of knowledge I know about you as
if you were completely identified with
your culture,
Your radiology snake.
It means you're the product of people
who lived before you,
not your own original thought.
Cause you buy den,
you've adapted the dogma,
which defines you.
It's not you.
It's the construction of people who were
damned ideologically Huh.
The catchword of an ideology as a
slogan.
Slogan is derived from the Welsh.
Like Gareth slowly,
Gareth means battle crime.
Yeah.
Which is a nice commentary on etiology.
Okay.
Um,
yes.
So it seems to,
okay,
so the right hemisphere seems to be
what,
what the process is doing,
what the king is doing.
They're the ones that are going out into
the unknown and the other ones that are,
that are using what they find,
um,
just for adaptive behavior.
Okay.
Hang on one note now.
It's not exactly right.
Okay.
Look chaos.
That's the dragon,
so to speak.
That's the possibility.
That's the unknown before it's being
contacted.
It's the unknown.
Hypothetically is the fact that behind
everything that you know,
there's this reality that you can say
anything about something that you
actually encounter that's unexpected,
that's the manifestation of the unknown
in your experience.
That's in the normally,
okay.
The right hemisphere is responsible for
point.
I think in conjunction with the limbic
system is responsible for pointing out
the fact of a normal is just to say that
if you're pursuing your goal directed
linguistically mediate plans and
something you didn't expect or curves,
then you're septal hippocampal and to
make delek systems grab your motor
behavior on your intention and force of
towards the anomaly.
Then you had,
then you make a decision process or
ignore and the thing that makes the
decision I think is the left is left
hemisphere.
It's the thing that decides whether it
will voluntarily make the descend or
will reject it.
So then what is it that,
because I think we experienced chaos
from the aspect of perspective when
we're completely dominated by the
processes of the right hemisphere,
which is to say the ASTEC does aspects
of Keanna,
sorry,
basically anxiety,
depression and while I think the third
category is sort of schizophrenia length
symptomatology,
this is right here,
Mr mediated.
We did not like that.
When when?
When your brain has flipped,
the woman is from the left hemisphere in
the right hemisphere,
you feel like dying.
In fact,
you might commit suicide.
[inaudible] that's,
I mean that's part of the reason why
people are very motivated not to bend.
The intention is to it to a normally is
the vase and its first manifestation.
It's anxiety provoking and painful.
But you have to balance that against
knowledge than if you don't pay
attention to it.
All that will happen is that it will
grow until instead of you facing it,
it will attack you likely when you're
weak.
Okay,
so,
so you have this anomalous pieces of
information.
Remind him as your focus is on the left
hemisphere says go after it or not,
or or ignore it and then does it then
call again to the right hemisphere to,
to,
to use patterns to identify it,
et Cetera.
And then,
well,
we'll keep that.
So that's a good question because the
thing about an anomalous experiences,
it doesn't present herself purely in
our,
in in its objective manifestation.
Let me give you an example.
So you're sitting in your apartment at
night,
it's quiet and you hear a noise that
shouldn't be in another room.
Okay,
so you're reading,
they have disrupts your reading.
I'd say here's something fall over.
Something big that disrupts your
reading.
It's like your goal directed activity
has,
has been eliminated.
It's like your alert,
you wait,
you might even wake up if you're asleep,
but you're alert.
So you walk cautiously.
But you might run out of the house.
That's one way of dealing with air.
You might fall in the police,
but let's say you decide to explore
while you're conflicted because you are
driven towards it,
but you're also angry,
anxious.
So you walked towards the room and let's
say the doors are like this and it's
dark in there and you reach your hand in
to trouble like you watch what your mind
does.
When you do that,
say if you watch the pictures the
degenerate because it's trying to figure
out what the hell is in there.
You'll get all sorts of fantasies about
the potential things that might be in
the next group.
If you actually watch yourself do this,
you generate,
what are some of the,
some of the visions will be more or less
we are less capital on and maybe it's
America,
but you also get images that are
monstrous,
like that's what's well,
that's both a hypothesis that your brain
is generating about what might've done
it.
A warning that something terrible might
be in that room because you don't like
you read it.
Do you know what?
I want to put your hand in there
and the anomaly all at once because it
already,
it emerges.
The anomaly emerges in a sense in
already categorized for,
that's the thing.
You never really encounter chaos per se.
As soon as something unexpected happens,
it's already presenting itself in the
form of a potential hypothesis,
so I think you're right.
Hemispheres is doing the pattern
recognition instantly.
So then it seems like the left
hemispheres that gets the decision
maker,
basically it just uses the right
hemisphere for for,
okay,
what is,
what is anomalous,
what give me the patterns and then let's
see how to use this for adaptive for my
adaptive behavior to get to the,
I think that,
I think that's,
I think that's how it works.
I think the information,
if there's a continuum between entirely
explored and not explored at all,
as information moves from the category
of no unexplored Vol,
two entirely explored.
It moves across the hemisphere so to
speak.
So the locale of specialization shifts
and there's evidence for this.
I mean the right hemisphere does seem to
be the place where activity takes place
most particularly when you don't know
what the hell you're doing.
Also,
the other thing that happens is the,
like if you're practicing in new
activity,
when you first start practicing huge
areas of the cortex light up and as you
get good at it,
the area that's involved gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller
until there's just a tiny center
somewhere.
It's really specialized for that
activity and then it's not conscious
anymore.
Can you do it automatically?
Piping and things?
Well,
I don't know about all right.
Well I don't know enough about the
literature on specialization.
Tell you what for I don't know where
motor patterns ended up localizing,
for example,
I don't think anybody knows.
We know that the prefrontal cortex is
involved in construction and monitoring
of motor plans when they're first being
formula,
but once they're perfected,
where are they go?
It seems still somewhat mysterious.
The uh,
yeah,
it seems involved in regulating the
smoothness of their,
of their,
uh,
of their application and the Basal
Ganglia are involved in motor.
I'll put two,
but where are those patterns are
localize.
I don't think anybody knows yet.
Seems a bit brash and generalize that to
have as business.
These are the possible ways,
separate.
Absolutely.
Patterns of activity.
Yes it is rubbish.
And the thing is is that broadly is,
this is broadly speaking and I don't
think it's so much a matter of
hemispheric specialization may be as
whether the information is
linguistically media.
There's still an image form or whether
it's an image form.
We're still at the level of behavior so
I know when you read it just isn't,
it's you risk simplification to think of
it in terms of hemispheric
specialization,
but there's still,
there's still enough useful information
to be driving that when you're making to
make it worthwhile.
So if you were to look at language then
could you say that that the organization
of thoughts and all that is left
hemisphere,
but let style and m the actual thoughts
coming from the right hemisphere?
Does it?
It doesn't seem right.
Well,
broadly again,
I would say that there's some evidence
for that.
Things like style that is pattern
recognition capacity.
I mean that's,
that's all.
Like the fond toner on a given type face
for example,
has nothing to do with the information
per se.
It's sort of an emergent property or or
styles and architecture,
literature and so on.
There are patterns there are difficult
to,
and I think they are related to two
story and image.
So
I know that you know that the right
hemisphere is specialized for the
comprehension of stories.
It is specialized for the comprehension
of patterns.
It's the hemisphere that's responsible
for your understanding of music and most
nonverbal cues.
It broadly specialized for negative
effect.
So,
and it's also architectonic [inaudible]
construct so that it has a left less
differentiated structure than the left
hemisphere,
which seems to indicate it's better for
quick and dirty analysis.
And I think what it does is use
metaphor.
It says this unknown thing,
kind of the same attributes as all these
other unexpected things that you've
already encountered.
So look out.
So which is useful information.
If you don't know anything else about
the unknown,
it's good to know that it's like all
those other things that you already
encountered that you didn't understand.
But I think what's happened with in
religious systems in large part is the
people have constructed images of the
unknown like Kelly,
and then use those as ritual models
against which to practice patterns about
amputation that are specialized.
Not for anything particular,
but for adaptation to the unknown in
general.
Because that's really what you have to
know,
not how to do something,
but how to do something when you don't
know how to do anything.
That's really what you need to know.
So you get things like the great goddess
who's responsible for death.
The only thing to her that's acceptable
is the human sacrifice.
But what does that mean?
Well,
they originally acting up,
and this says,
to get from here to here,
to make an adjustment to the fact of
chaos requires constant sacrifice.
What?
Sacrifice up at king,
for example,
that the king is a pattern of adaptive
behavior before you can understand that
in the image or semantically yanked it
out,
and that's where those rituals come
from.
So that plaque,
kate's the goddess,
endless sacrifice.
Well,
that's right,
but what is it?
Well.
It's endless sacrifice of that thing
that you value most,
which is in fact in the abstract and for
your current set of beliefs and your
configuration,
your view of the world,
the thing you want to give up the least
because it's the thing that protects you
from emotional chaos.
That's what you have to sacrifice all
the time in order to adapt to the fact
of the unknown.
Okay.
Now back to social psychology.
I want to read you these things familiar
[inaudible].
This is very interesting
for religious man.
Space is not homogenous.
He experienced his interruptions and
breaks in it.
Some parts of space are qualitatively
different from others.
Drawing not nigh.
Hither says the Lord unto Moses,
put off my shoes from off they feet for
the place where I'm they'll stand is
holy ground.
Exodus three five there is then a sacred
space,
enhance a strong,
significant space.
There are other spaces that are not
sacred and so our without consistency or
core structure,
they're amorphous have no definition,
nor is this all for religious man.
This spatial lauren homogeneity finds
expression and the experience of an
opposition between space that is sacred,
the only real and really existing space
and all other space,
the formless expanse that surrounds it.
Okay.
It must be set at once that the
religious experience of the [inaudible]
spaces and primordial experience,
he means by that an archetype experience
doesn't have to be learned.
It's a structural element of experience.
Homologeo Homo Habilis homologous to the
founding of the world.
It is not a matter of theoretical
speculation,
but have a primary religious experience
that precedes all reflection on the,
on the world,
okay.
Or just the break effect in the space
that allows the world to be cost to to
that because it reveals a fixed point.
The central access for all future
orientation.
When the sacred manifest itself,
there was not only a break in the emoji
native space,
there's also a revelation of an absolute
reality of the non reality of the bass
around the expanse,
the manifestation of the sacred
ontologically founds the world.
Okay.
Now what Eliade is trying to say,
look,
you're a cognitive systems are founded
upon certain preset positions.
What did I eliade is trying to do,
and this was a guild was trying to do
too with this idea of vacation with the
archetype is just to point out what are
the most fundamental levels of
presuppositions upon which all the
things that you think.
In fact,
our baits as Kurt Gadell pointed out
that any,
any internally cysts,
any internal and consistent system,
logical system is necessarily predicated
on presumptions and the can be approved
from within the system.
They have to be accepted.
Their axioms,
like Deon seems of geometry.
This is an axiom.
There's defined territory and undefined.
This is what you protect.
This is where you live.
It's the establishment of this.
That is the precondition for everything
else you do.
So establishing that initial sacred
space,
that's a religious act,
the primary religious act.
So what is clear?
So it's clear to what it'd be grieved.
That discovery that is the revelation of
sacred space,
possesses existential value for
religious man.
For nothing can begin.
Nothing can be done without a previous
orientation in any orientation implies
acquiring a fixed point.
It is for this reason that religious man
has always sought to fix his abode at
the center of the world.
That's where the medieval notion that
man exists,
whether it be earth was the center of
the cosmos.
That's where that idea came from.
It wasn't an empirical notion.
It was the notion that wherever we live,
that's the center that's defined space
surrounded necessarily by an expanse of
territory that we haven't explored.
Now we already know to what to make of
that in terms of implications because we
know what an unexplored territory
signifies.
First.
It's signifies fear and it signifies
promise.
So defined territory is security
established in an expanse of anxiety and
and curiosity.
Funny but eight priority.
It's anxiety.
So you're a village is surrounded by the
places you don't know because it's
frightening out there.
Why is it frightening?
No behavioral structures have been
erected to make that space habitable.
So it's the domain of monsters.
It's the domain of wolves.
It's the domain of foreigners.
It's the domain of barbarians.
It's the place that you can explore.
It's like the old maps,
the whole medieval maps of the world to
find territory amorphous just surrounded
by ocean with monsters.
That's what that means.
There were monsters out there and
unknown territory.
That's,
it's interesting too,
cause the most is always take the form
of whales.
But Wales aren't whales for medieval
people.
And if they didn't know what Wales,
where there are serpents,
sea surface that live in the sea and if
you go out there out beyond explored
territory,
the sea serpent comes out of the sea and
swallows you.
Perhaps the hero's mission right down
into the belly of the beast.
You might come back and you might not.
But what that is is the projection of
mythology on the world.
So for the European exploration was an
extraordinary radical.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Yes.
Yeah,
I did.
Well here I going to tell you exactly
exactly how radical that was.
This is something in reality is that
pains to describe what are the
outstanding characteristics of
traditional societies is the opposition
that they assume between their inhabited
territory,
ambien determinant space that surrounds
it.
The former is the world more precisely
our world.
The cosmos.
So when Marta constructs the cosmos,
that's what that means is he's
constructing habitable territory,
the definable world out of the amorphous
reality that surrounds it.
Okay?
Everything outside of the cosmos is no
longer cosmos,
but it's sort of other world,
a foreign chaotic place by ghosts,
demons,
foreigners who are assimilated to demons
into the souls of the dead.
Now this is,
this is some other research,
that idea.
So this is an insert more specifically
to the dragon of chaos.
Okay?
So this is the point here.
Your natural category of foreigner is
the dragon of chaos.
They're in the same category.
Not because you've assimilated them
together,
but because you have not yet
distinguished them.
They're still the same thing.
So your natural response to the
foreigner is he's the thing that isn't
human that occupies the space defined by
chaos.
Who's a primary motivational
significance is the generation of terror
and disorder.
She say you don't get an explanation
then about why people are hostile with
the foreigners.
What you need is an explanation for
those few instances where that does not,
in fact,
they'll curve
okay?
In,
Among the Hicks sauce.
Barbarians were assimilated to Apophis
who do borrowers?
The Sun,
no,
sorry.
Yeah,
that's right
Hicks.
Those were barbarians from the Egyptian
point of view.
They kept coming into Egypt and
disrupting everything.
They were assimilate hicks sauce met
barbarians,
and they were simulated to apophis who
devours the sun.
Okay,
so that's the Egyptians among the Indo
Europeans,
the ancestors of the mortar,
the Indians,
the assimilation of enemies in back,
nope,
to the slaying of [inaudible].
In fact,
enemies were called Burton's and Virta
was the gigantic dragon who held back
the waters in the hollow of the
mountain.
Interests laid him and constructed the
world.
So for the Indo Europeans,
the slang and enemies was precisely
equivalent to the act that constructed
the world.
And that is because when you slay your
enemies,
you expand your territory in the
expansion of territory is equivalent
construction in the world.
It's a heroic enterprise.
You're battling the enemies of the state
among the Zoroastrians and the ram.
He will,
trump's in the battle.
He truly kills me.
I'm sorry,
the fight of the hero three tournament
against the dragon as they hakka is
recounted as the struggle of King Fair
done against the foreign new surfer,
the dragon as to hack and it's the same
story.
This is an arrhenius foreigners or the
dragon of chaos.
They bring disorder into the state,
so to overthrow the forerunner,
to establish new territories to to the
same thing that the day he did what he
established the world
now.
Okay.
At first this cleavage,
the first side.
This cleavage in space appear to be due
to the opposition between an inhabited
and organize hands,
cosmo sized territory and the unknown
space that expands beyond its frontiers.
On one side there's a cosmos on the
other side of cameras,
but we shall see that if every inhabited
territory is a cosmos,
this is precisely because it was first
consecrated because in one way or
another it is the work of the garden
cards or is in communication with the
world of the guards who determine
destiny in that territory and who
therefore caused the toothy organizing
principles of the society,
the dominance hierarchy that rules
there.
That's the thing,
you know,
inside say can space.
You're all,
you're pursuing a goal that's shared by
everyone else that's in that space.
So their behavior is all random,
predictable as a consequence of their
participation in the same story.
It's a religious story.
This defined by the dominance of the
certain God.
So when you go out into new territory,
the first thing you do is consecrate
that new territory to the God that rules
your territory.
So the order rules,
order rains there,
that means the world's created and what
it means,
that order range there is that whenever
other people go there,
they have to behave the same way you
behave.
So they're predictable.
So that means they're out of the domain
that's defined by CAS.
And they don't terrify.
You don't undermine.
They don't pose the possibility of
undermining everything that it is that
you believe in.
So lem,
it says all this appears very clearly
from the thing that ritual for taking
possession of the territory that
shouldn't becomes legally valid through
the erection of a fire alter consecrated
to Agni.
Is this a quote from the religious
texts?
The shout of path that Brovana one,
he says that what is installed,
when,
what has built a fire altered and all
those who build the fire alter our
legally established.
Okay,
so this is rules for in California,
New Territory
by the erection of a fire alter Agni is
made present.
You see a fire,
the erection of a firewall to,
that's a symbol of the construction of
civilization,
right?
And because the mastery of fire is
something that is absolutely integral to
the establishment of border anyways,
but the meaning of the ritual is far
more complex.
And if we consider all of its
ramifications,
we shall understand why concentrating
your territory is equivalent to making
it a cosmos for in fact,
the erection of an alternate Agni is
nothing but the rep production on the
microcosmic scale of the creation,
the water in which the clay is mixed,
the clay.
So the altered is assimilated to the
primordial water chaos.
The client that forms the base of the
altar symbolizes the earth.
The lateral walls represent the
atmosphere and so on.
And the building of the alters and
company by songs that proclaim which
caused region.
It's just being created.
Hence the erection of a fire altered
which alone validates taking possession
of her new territory is equivalent to
the construction of the world and I'm
known for an unoccupied territory which
usually means unoccupied by our people.
Still shares in the fluid and larva
modality of chaos,
my occupying it and above all by
settling it man symbolically transform
it,
it transforms it into a cosmos,
through a ritual repetition of the
creation of the world.
What is to become our world must first
be created and every creation as a
paradigmatic mortal creation of the
universe by the guards.
When the Scandinavian calling this,
this took position of Iceland and
cleared it,
they regarded the enterprise.
Neither has an original undertaking,
nor is human and profane work.
For them.
The was the repetition of a priority
will act and transformation of chaos
into cosmos by the divine.
After creation.
When they tilt the deserted soil,
they were in fact repeating the act of
the gardens.
So was organized chaos by giving it a
structure,
forums and norms,
whether it is a case of clearing
uncultivated grown or conquering and
occupying and territory already
inhabited by other human beings.
Ritual taking possession must always
repeat the cosmogony from the view of
archaic societies.
Everything that is not our world is not
yet the world.
The territory can only be made ours by
creating a new this religious behavior
and respect.
Unknown lands continued even in the west
down to the daughter of in times Spanish
and Portuguese.
Conquistadores discovering and
conquering territory is took possession
of them in the name of Jesus Christ.
The raising of the cross was equivalent
to Carson crating which country?
Hanson some way to a new birth for
through Christ.
All things are passed away.
Behold all things become new.
Two Corinthians five 17 the newly
discovered country was the nude
recreated by the cross.
Of course,
and when the Americans landed on the
moon,
the first thing they did was put up the
American flag.
It's a profane repetition of precisely
the same notions.
This is this undiscovered territory is
now part of the world order rules there
in North Carolina.
So also Lord,
through the ritual after that,
because like in the
bag agonize like the fire guys,
your guide of transformation.
So if you're transforming that land from
that,
which is honest,
it that which is explore,
right and thereby making it
simultaneously sacred part of it.
Sacred territory.
Yep.
Okay.
Yup,
that's right.
That's exactly right.
In the ritual that you undergo when
you're creating the fire temple is
equivalent to participating in the act.
For example.
That's defined by Marduk.
Just the,
the fighting with the Dragon.
That's reference till I read it.
I think the reason you might think this
is completely off the wall,
but I've thought about for a long time,
it makes a certain amount of sense to
me.
Chaos is represented by a drag.
Why?
Why are you dragging the urge?
Any dragons?
But it's partly because the dragon is a
creature of the of matter because it's a
serpent and it goes around on the ground
and has wings.
So it's also a creature of the air,
so it's a symbol of the union of
opposites,
right?
It's also a serpent so it can shed its
skin and be reborn.
So there's an element of transformation
in there.
But I always saw this great picture.
It's a picture from the medieval church.
It's called souls in the grip of hell.
And there's,
there's a picture of this monstrous
dragon and inside it's wood carving
inside.
If there's all these people who have
hard,
horrified expressions on their face,
but maybe being devoured by a serpent.
Now
we share our ascending spinal tracks on
their limbic system with animals.
The pulling a long ways back on the file
of genetic chain and our limbic system
and the cameras.
This is all as amphibians.
In fact,
the hippocampus first made its
appearance win.
Our rn says to his crawled out of the
water,
which is kind of kind of interesting
from a symbolic perspective.
I think the reason that the dragon of
chaos as symbolized by the dragon is
because when we fall into that,
our actions and aspects are dominated by
parts of our brain that are so old.
But they still partake in the aspect of
the world is defined by my reptilian
potency.
Anyways,
you can think about that.
I mean I debated whether or not to,
to make a point about it in this
manuscript cause it seems to be kind of
a strange notion,
but the fact is there are dragons
everywhere in the world and they're
representative of something.
Okay.
So we
thank in these ways and draw these
distinctions naturally.
It's not a feature of the object.
So we would tend to think of,
well it depends on how you define the
object.
Right?
Thank you.
These ways,
even when the territory that we're
exploring isn't a spacial object,
even if it's something abstract,
like a concept.
Absolutely.
Hello.
Our ideological concepts around,
especially in your logical concepts or
actually abstract representations of
adaptive behavioral patterns,
they're not descriptions of the
objective world.
Like if you share a Marxist ideology,
Marxist ideology is a body of laws,
which basically means that it's a verbal
representation of a pattern of action.
This designed to transform order into
chaos,
and order.
Although with the Marxist state works
the other way round.
So that's right.
You're any illogical identification is
in fact your abs,
your identification with uh,
with a god of behavior that's become
abstract that into a higher order
philosophy.
Okay.
But don't you think,
I mean obviously in those situations
then you can use that as an impetus to
fight or to have more.
Okay.
In some cases the fact that it's not a
spacial object or a literal possession
or territory or land might change the
way that we approach it.
I mean we'd still approach it in the
same way in our mind,
but the consequence,
no,
I think it's worse.
I think it's worse because look if was,
if you've taken it on the wall then you
train it so that it,
so that it's adapted to a territory you
can't come along and have an argument
with it and thereby undermine its whole
sequence of that applications.
Like once the animal is gone and sat
down,
station fixed about the only thing you
can do to really follow it up is to
shift its environment.
Like you can move it somewhere else.
But if you have abstracted your patent
and about adaptation up into an ideology
that's verbally mediate,
and I'd come along with a set of
principles that it make logical
nonsense.
If some of your presuppositions,
I can blow apart whole schemes of you're
an adaptation in the course of say an
afternoon and it might take a long time
for the consequences of that to like
have their effect on all your structures
about amputation.
But the point is is that one side
transformed my adaptations into words.
I can adapt abstract and that's where
the useful,
right?
I mean I can build potential adaptive
models in the abstract without having to
ask them.
No,
that's the positive side.
But the negative side is this.
Once I can abstract out the principles,
I'm really vulnerable to an argument.
And what an argument is is a war that
sparked with works and if it fails then
we just cascade down the chain of
abstraction to the actual part of the
way.
So
I'm not going to ask you about.
So I guess what I'm trying to get at is
something more like if there,
like if there is a fertile valley,
10 miles outside of mine order and
you're there.
I have to,
if I'm not going to cooperate with you,
I have to kill you in order for me to
have that in order for me to explore it
and for it to be mine.
But if I'm studying astrophysics and
you're an astrophysicist in China,
I don't necessarily have to kill you in
order for me to be able to study even
the exact same thing that you're
studying.
But you kill this person by firing off
letters undermine.
Sure.
Well look,
that's it.
That's it.
No,
that's a good,
that's a good example because there's no
necessary reason why a scientific model
has to simultaneously take on the effect
of Valence of an adaptation or more.
But to the degree that your career is
contaminated with your ideas,
you're going to respond to your
competitors as if they were enemies.
So if you've abstracted yourself from
your objective ideas,
which basically means if you have a
light,
it's independent of your scientific
beliefs,
then you can treat them as objective
elements and there's no necessary reason
for you to get your emotions involved.
But the truth,
like the real situation tends not to be
that way.
As the people get their objective
pictures tangled up with their religious
beliefs,
and then they do view attacks on their
domain as personal attacks.
But you're not supposed to do that in
science.
In fact,
science is actually the mechanism
whereby we separate those two types of
models,
but it doesn't always work.
So,
so it seems
like if you're like,
like when you're literally exploring the
actual physical world,
it's absolutely inevitable there's going
to be physical violence and conflict.
And there's no even possibility of
getting around that.
I mean,
in principle that isn't necessarily part
of it.
But then so is it wrong to say then that
when you're no longer studying the
physical world and when you're studying
more abstract things that most likely
you're probably still going to behave
the same way,
but there's at least the possibility
that you can,
no,
I wouldn't say,
okay.
I will.
No,
I wouldn't say that like I don't think
if you're studying things that are
objective,
you have in principle the possibility of
being objective about when you didn't
have to fight over it.
If there's one thing and we both won and
won't cooperate,
we must for sure it
didn't like about your apartment.
Right?
Right.
There are all like your,
your first premise was the bloodshed was
a necessary intermediate.
Okay,
but that's not one of the things we want
to do in this course.
The reason that I'm interested in the
structure of myth to begin with is to
figure out,
look,
here's your alternatives.
If I let your ideas in my head and then
I end up in chaos,
that's one option.
Okay,
so I don't let you,
right.
Isn't the body you have by killing you?
That's another option.
Now,
both of those options seem to me to be
pretty,
pretty distressing.
You can't expect me to give up
everything I believe in just because you
have different idea.
By the same token,
if the only way that we can settle our
disputes is through force and you'll
have an involvement.
I have one,
well that's pretty much the end of the
story in there too,
so it's sort of anxiety,
depression and the possibility of
suicide and cultural degeneration on one
side or like conflict.
It will kill us both on the other side.
Right.
Those are the,
you might describe those as the horns of
a dilemma,
but then the question is,
well,
given that dilemma,
what's the,
is there an alternative path?
Well,
that's what we're hopefully going to
define mostly in the second part of the
course because that's the dilemma.
It's a terrible dilemma mean before if
you had an ax as stone axes and sticks
and so did I,
and we have fight,
well,
there was at least the possibility that
one of our groups wasn't going to end
up.
But now when we're talking about
territorial disputes between hours that
are fully armed,
the possibility for settling the problem
violently.
It doesn't even exist unless you're
willing to,
unless you'd be willing to kill me
unless you'd be willing to die just to
kill me.
Which of course is always a possibility.
And it's now like how deep your desire
for revenge action is.
So,
so the middle road is always a
compromise or having,
because your copper,
if you have an argument with Sonia
men's,
you take a little of their idea and then
it'll enough of yours so that you're so
that you're going to get along.
And if you have a,
if you're have a more sort of physical
situation,
you're just compromised in terms of
getting what you want.
Isn't that,
isn't that exactly what,
what culture is is compromised so that
everyone,
well a certain part of your providers
because if you had are modifying our
behavior in some territory,
part of it's dispute,
but part of it's,
well if you do this I'll reward you and
if I do this you'll reward me.
And so like it's positive mutual,
a modification,
but also words.
I can't have everything I could possibly
want.
I mean if I could just have everything I
could possibly want,
I would not function and this economic
function in society.
All right,
right.
You get,
what you do is essentially theoretically
is you'd give up some immediate
gratification for the longterm protect
possibility.
I've continued stable gratification.
I mean that's one way of looking at it
or at least being able to live in
society,
which I have to do.
Right,
exactly.
Exactly.
That's the social contract sort of
notion right now.
So,
but you said compromise and I would say,
well rather,
so if you know,
here's your negative option one,
which is I kill you and here's maybe
option two,
which is I listened to you and thereby
lose all my faith.
Well then the question is like,
is there some need a principal that
isn't either of these that can be used
instead of them?
And I would say,
well that's why we're studying what
Marta represents.
Because I would say at the core of all
belief systems is a representation of
the process by which the belief system
was erected,
which is the most important thing about
the belief system.
So if you're,
you have belief system may that you're
like dogmatically attached to and I have
a belief system B and I'm dogmatic,
the attached to it.
And I point out to you that despite our
differences that the core,
the most important thing is something
that we actually both agree about that
might help in some way smooth the
possibility of transition.
It would also make us at least
reasonable negotiators because,
well,
here's an example.
You have to see if I want to negotiate
with you,
we need a higher order point of
reference that defines the rules because
otherwise I might make an agreement with
you and then just like how don't you
went to shreds is the first chance like,
yeah,
right?
So you have to be able to trust me even
to begin the process of negotiation.
So I would say,
well this is a weird example,
but let's say in,
in the Christian marriage ceremony and
white table that is the union of two
disparate territory's.
Well,
the notion is,
is that the male and the female want to
with post to subordinate themselves to
the process.
The Christ represents smart,
smarter,
and Horace,
et Cetera,
and in breath and Buddha.
And why is that?
Well,
because this person has,
you know,
their story and this person has their
story and you didn't have the stores
produces a lot of unknown territory like
right away.
And in order to mediate between the two
can,
you know,
higher order principle,
which says,
so that's the rule.
So it's like,
okay,
I'll negotiate with you,
but you have to trust me.
And vice versa.
We have to put the possibility of trust
above all our dispute.
So you'd say what trust is one of the
aspects here,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So then we have a higher point of
reference to mediate or just be it.
So I'm saying,
well,
this is one territory,
this is another.
We need to find out what rules the
unexplored spaces in between so that
when we get there we know how to act.
Say
One more question about that similar
sort of thing.
What if the type of thing that you want
to explore it isn't the type of thing
that inherently precludes like there's
sometimes the things that if I want to
have it,
I must keep everyone else from having it
in order that I can have it.
Yeah,
that's a zero sum game.
Right?
And there are other sorts of things that
aren't that way.
Like for instance,
if,
if I just had this dispute that I
couldn't resolve with the Chinese,
astrophysics says I would not
necessarily need to even knowledge that
he was studying something.
I mean I,
well that's true.
Look it up on it.
There are going to be like,
I wouldn't have to fight.
This is your story and this is his
story.
You both established domains of reality.
Cosmo,
cosmo's,
oh,
the plural of that is to costs
as long as he's studying phenomena that
are relevant to your pursuits.
But even if studying,
again,
that same thing,
I did not have to keep him from studying
it just so that I can study it.
You not have to kill him as long as,
as long as the implications of what he
discovers have no negative significance
for your ongoing story.
That's,
that's,
yeah.
It seems like when you're
like just solely to the physical world,
like in rivers and who's going to own
the valley,
then if you're not willing to cooperate
and you're not going to give up your
goal and you have to kill them.
But if it's an abstracted thing,
like you're not studying a particular
tree yours,
but you're just studying a concept.
Yeah.
And even if he wants to stay in the
exact same bit of territory,
well he don't make that argument about
limited territory too all the time.
Cause they say because there's some
economists to basically follower,
which population theorist who said we
were all destined to starve my office.
Yeah.
There's somebody coming in a suit taken
both thoseand perspective,
which is that everything is a zero sum
game.
And so the competition for resources as
necessary.
And there's others who say,
well no,
that's not true because you redefined
territory by transforming your adaptive
structure.
And that means that what may look like
bounded territory is only bounded
because of the way that you approach it.
And if you think of a new way to
approach it,
well then there's plenty of resources
for all.
And so far the [inaudible] ones I think
are winning the argument,
which is to say that territory is
defined by your behavior in it,
not by any objective aspects of the
territory.
So,
you know,
he was a jury of distinction between
over goods and really these are really
structures of belief.
Uh,
I mean it seems like you can,
I would say,
I would say not,
not usually,
because what constitutes a good,
it's always construed in relationship to
the pursuit of a goal.
It's like we fight wars over oil and the
20th century,
but we wouldn't fight wars over oil and
the 19th century because the effect of
the effect of Valence of petroleum has
shifted as a consequence of a shift and
in our environmental structure.
So and that's a natural good,
so to speak,
but like I don't buy the concept of
natural resource,
I think.
I think there's a real flawed logic
somewhere there because natural resource
plays the same role in economic theory
as stimuli does in psychology.
I mean suddenly they were like,
we agree that oil is a good and so we're
fighting over it.
Yeah.
That's then just say that I look at the
world in such a way that I don't think
the world very differently out of the
world in such a way that your way of
looking at the world is inherently a
threat to it because it's different from
my,
from mine and so it's not exactly that
we can compromise.
We have to come up with some integrative
principal.
Right?
Absolutely.
That's why it was taking dispute
fighting over oil.
It seems to me,
yes.
I would say yes because we can't.
In other words,
we have to get to some other level so to
speak.
Yeah.
We should do that with the fight over
oil too,
because there should be a higher,
theoretically at least there might be a
higher order set of principles to which
we would be willing to subordinate our
competition for oil.
Yeah,
I mean,
and it seems,
I don't think it's not,
I don't think it's unreasonably Utopian
to presume that in the long run it would
be better if we could get as much as
possible for everyone.
It would be like from the selfish
perspective,
better like think it was a historically,
enormously van,
for example,
that the Americans rebuilt Japan instead
of burning into the ground and plowing
you down.
You're with salt,
which is your more standard human
response to demolish,
demolished enemy.
And it was the same Mikey said about
Germany,
but the addition of Japan to the world
economic power strikes me as a net
benefit even to the victors evil,
which was a well union.
Well that plus the Japanese are online,
so to speak.
We have access to the creative
intelligence of an additional several
hundred million people or however many
people inhabit Japan.
So that's,
it's not a zero sum game.
There's no necessary reason to construe
it as a zero sum game.
It can be played that way,
but it's,
I think it's an error so that eliminates
the known,
the notion of the distinction between
like limited resources and ideas because
resources are ideas.
Let's see.
When I look at,
I mean I think I do,
so I see this danger that you're in.
Couldn't get any theologies and fight
wars over them,
but on the other hand,
to me they seem,
it seems to present a more optimistic
playing field because just if we have
this drive to explore that must be so
satisfied and we want,
we want to explore the physical
environment.
We must fight.
We must either cooperate or fight
because if there's one object and that
there aren't duplicate copies of it and
only one person can explore it,
I must,
yeah,
I see what I can both explored
independent,
well that don't even need to talk.
I always,
the farm with the space race was good
for that for precisely that reason.
It's a great,
it's a great outlet for necessary
explored very Tennessee.
It would not necessarily,
I see what you mean.
Yeah.
I haven't been saying all along.
And the whole point of abstraction and
sort of in terms of evolutionary
development is so that you can figure
out what's good and bad without actually
going out there and getting slaughtered
by it's bad.
So therefore,
and the,
our whole cultural system is being
extracted so that you can have,
you can do these things where it hasn't
actually,
but it has a very,
the problem with it is that it has this
attended a danger that we haven't
discussed,
which is the Tam Cascade.
You can also blow your whole system.
It's like that's,
I think that's what we did with the
site.
I guess I should some smell.
It's not quite three.
When the scientific revolution came
about,
the discoveries of the scientific
revolution in abstract form seem to
contradict the presumptions of the
religious systems upon which we erected
are a deputational structures.
So the consequence of abstraction was
that we could destroy our belief systems
and that brought on an existential
crisis.
So the problem with abstraction is yes,
you can explore the abstract is very
powerful.
But you can also be undermined really
easily by words.
So what another reason it's really
useful to study your theology I think is
because it gives your ideology,
your necessary believe that kind of from
ground they can no longer be your mind
easily by a few casual words.
Cause you're north,
you're no longer.
If you think about it as a tree,
you're way up here in the branches,
you haven't got the foggiest clue what's
down here.
It's all unconscious so to speak,
which is to say it's all procedural.
Lord still embed images.
Somebody would come along and give you a
bit of harassment here and it blows your
whole adoptation we'll structure apart.
You hate that.
I mean it's,
it's very hard on you.
But that's mostly because you don't know
what's down here.
So your house is built on shifting sand,
no one on the rock.
And the point is you're supposed to
this,
this ties in with the philosopher's
stone inventory that we'll get to in the
second half of the course.
But the idea is that you're supposed to
build your house on a rock.
And the point is you have to figure out
what that rock is.
And that's,
that's part of the reason why we're
spending so much time to discussing this
pattern of adaptation.
Because if you know that in your belief
system is description of the process by
which belief systems are generated and
that's the thing that you need to do
above all else,
well it makes you much more resistant to
casual disruption of your,
of your adaptations structure.
Cause you know what you should do when
you don't know what to do,
which is the thing you need to know the
most.
So
they're reading.
Oh,
that's a good question.
The simple answer would be yes.
Let me see.
Well you use the abuse of history is
pretty short.
The basic writings of nature.
No,
you don't have to read all that.
Read beyond good and evil as much of it
as you can.
It's very difficult to read.
But,
but it's very useful.
The great mother.
Well look are the reason that I signed
the great mother is because it's the
most comprehensive survey I know of.
The symbolism of novelty basically of
the great mother.
And what you should do is go through it
and get familiar with what it is that
new saying.
Basically all he's doing is saying,
well,
there's a sim.
He thinks it's the collective
unconscious by the way,
which is right in a sense there's a
domain,
it's the unknown.
It has a positive side,
the negative side.
Here's the symbols that have accumulated
around that domain in representation.
If you read that,
like go through it enough so that you
get a feel for the language of the
symbols,
which basically means you have to
understand when you see the statue of
Diana who has a multitude of breasts,
you have to understand what that image
signifies,
how when you see Kelly who has,
who's eating someone she's giving birth
to,
you have to be able to see it.
No one has a foreign artifact but as a
representation of something that you
understand,
so you have to read that book and a half
until you get the language.
The reason for that is because unless
you can,
unless you understand those mythological
representations,
you have no idea how terrifying the
thing is that you want to avoid.
Because in normal circumstances it are
well protected existences.
We never ever encounter anything but
scares us badly enough to let us know
how scared we could be.
If you look at these mythological
representations,
you can get an abstract notion of how
terrifying territory really is and it's
very useful.
Get instant insight into other,
into the artistic productions of arcade
cultures.
So,
and uh,
the origins and history of
consciousness.
Well
that's basically the best book that I do
have.
It describes hero mythology.
So again,
you have to go through these enough so
that you get the gist of what the
authors are trying to,
are trying to describe.
In the great mother Newman describes the
symbolism of north in the origins and
history of consciousness.
He describes the symbolism of the
process that explores novelty.
So again,
you want to get a picture of it cause
then you'll start understanding
references to heroes and so on.
As we,
as we proceed through that,
through the divorce or these ordering?
No,
not really.
Not really.